Honest hemingway was a man's man.
He was a war hero,
a big game hunter from
an adventure and bands,
a bubble.
Laos a storyteller,
yet his was a leaf.
It fills with contrasts.
During his early years,
the future match.
Mom's mother dressed and
treated him as a girl,
met his own son.
Gregory would become made transvestite.
He was also known as Papa Hemingway,
but he had a distant relationship
with his own three sons.
In the midst of the glowing tributes
that the world heaped upon him,
he sunk two terrible lows causing
turmoil as he racked up awards.
And then finally,
in an act of desperation,
he took his own life.
Does say that Hemingway,
it was a complex individual,
is perhaps the ultimate understatement.
And in today's biographics video,
we're going to do our best to discover
the real man behind the veneer of Papa
Hemingway.
Hmm.
Honest Miller Hemingway
was born on July 1st,
1899 at two eds and grace.
Hemingway.
Ed was a doctor in the
Chicago suburb of Oak Park.
Grace was he talented opera singer who
had been forced to give up a province in
Korea.
Do you deport her eyesight?
She was to replace the adulation she could
have received by being a star with an
abnormal obsession with her children.
For the first six years of his life,
young Ernie was dressed and
treated as a girl by his mother.
She had always wanted twin girls and
made her son play that role to his older
sister Masalin as if FTU counter the
feminizing influences of his wife Ed.
He was a keen outdoorsman,
would take his son camping alongside
Lake Michigan for two months every year.
The honest was allowed to dress as a boy.
Ends was introduced to do the
manly arts of hunting and fishing.
Having where he though he remembered
his father is a cruel man edge.
It was often harsh to as children.
If they misbehaved after
whipping them with a razor strap,
he would make them pray
to God for forgiveness.
The Sun that developed a deep hatred
for his father or eating that he would
sometimes go into the shed shoulder,
his father's hunting rifle and
line up the old man in his sights.
Still,
he was able to restrain himself
from pulling that trigger.
Now in high school and his strive
to be the center of attention.
He was popular with his classmates
throwing himself into every game,
activity or prank.
Yet,
despite his enthusiasm,
he was not a very good sportsman,
still wanting to impress.
He would make up stories about his prowess
on the football fields and took these
friends and family.
It was in the creation of these tall tales
that Ernest Hemingway was to discover
his true gift as a writer.
It was Hemingway's English teacher that
noticed his talents with the pen and
encouraged the boys to try
out for the school newspaper.
He wanted a place on the writing team
and we seem to publish his first story.
The theme of that story would resonate
with Hemingway for the rest of his life.
Coming to a tragic conclusion,
45 years later,
the short story,
it was cool to a judgement at [inaudible]
and it was about a hunter who ends his
life in a suicide.
The story it was well
received and Hemingway was
spurred on to pursue a career
in journalism against the wishes of his
father who fully intended to become a
doctor.
The boy's uncle.
He was the friends of a tennis
shoe at the Kansas City.
Star arranged an apprenticeship
as a cub reporter.
This 17 year old wants
to handle the crime beat.
Hemingway absolutely threw
himself into this job.
The first task was to
devour the stars style book,
which was based upon their
unique abbreviated pro style.
It demands it the use of short sentences
and introductory paragraphs along with
simple language with an
emphasis on vigorous English.
I think we would recall that this was
the best writing advice that did it ever
received.
The entry of the United States into
the first world war in 1917 was a major
turning point in Hemingway's life.
The patriotic fervor that was sweeping
the nation's youth coupled with his in
his enthusiasm for adventure,
swept him up as he tried to join the
army rejected because he had defective
vision.
He tried it again this time applying to
the Red Cross ambulance division in SLE
before in us.
Well,
he was on a ship to Europe.
Hmm.
Who is it easily?
There's Hemingway was to get his first
experience of the madly comradery and
freedom.
That was to mean so much to him.
He was able to drink,
gambled Ben's corrals into the
early hours with absolute impunity.
Yes.
What do you really longs for?
That was combat far away
from the front lines.
His days were mainly spends in monotonous,
dreary tasks.
He confided to her friends.
I'm fed up,
there's nothing here that
scenery and too damn much of us.
I'm going to get out of this ambulance
section and see if I can't find out where
this war is.
Pretty soon the wall,
well,
it came to him on July the eighth 1918
he was delivering chocolate rations and
cigarettes to Italian
soldiers on the PA river.
He got caught in the middle of a German
offensive from the other side of the
water.
A bomb exploded,
throwing Hemingway to the ground.
The soldier alongside him was killed,
but honest escaped with
shrapnel wounds to his leg.
Despite this,
he managed to carry a wounded soldier
to safety before collapsing into
unconsciousness the way.
Well,
he now became a patient at the Red Cross
hospital in Milan and it was in this
hospital where he found his
first glove lying in bed.
He became captivated with an American
volunteer nurse by the name of agonist,
savant neuroscape during
his month recuperation and
it's an agonist explored the
sites of Milan together,
I think weight.
He became a numbered with a dark haired
beauty who was seven years his senior
huffy things.
However,
they were not so strong
despite to marry him.
At the war's end on New Year's Eve,
1918 having way it was discharged from
the Red Cross and returned to the family
home in Oak Park.
He took on the persona of a returning
war hero telling the local paper that he
was a soldier in the Italian army and
relating how we had been personally
decorated by the Italian king for bravery.
Something that totally never happens.
Okay.
Hemingway's postwar high,
it was shattered by a breakup
letter from agonists in it.
She wrote,
I am now and always will be too old,
and that's the truth as I can't get away
from the facts that you're just a boy.
A kid.
This through earnest into a tailspin,
he spends months loafing around
the house until it's fed up.
Mother finally tired
of just moping around,
threw him out,
grace while she gave him some
sounds and sobering advice.
Unless you my son,
earnest CCR,
lazy loafing or trading on
your handsome face to food,
gullible little girls and neglecting
your duty to God and your savior,
Jesus Christ.
Unless you come into your manhood,
there is nothing before
you but bankruptcy.
Whether this jolt of reality woke
him up or not is still uncertain,
but what we do know is that it was enough
to get earnest out of his funk and on
his way to Chicago there he wrote articles
for the Toronto Star and worked odd
jobs to support himself as a party.
One night,
honest Matt,
a young woman by the name
of Hadley Richardson,
oddly was on a visit to the
big city from Saint Louis.
Having led a sheltered life under the
influence of a domineering mother?
Yes,
she had Ernest hit it off immediately
and despite the fact that she was eight
years older than him seems young army.
How do you think for older women,
the relationship blossomed?
Nine months later,
earnest and Hadley,
they were married,
I guess down to the wedding was show would
Anderson and up and coming writer who
a friend it Anderson encouraged
the newlyweds to move to Paris.
He gave out us.
That is an introduction,
so you literary friends,
he resided on the left bank managing
it to secure a position as a foreign
correspondent for the Toronto Star.
Having weight took his bride and
departed for a new life in Europe.
Hmm.
I think,
wait.
He quickly inserted itself into the
litter recess on Paris's left bank.
The couple moved into a small flat,
which sat next to a poppy that dance
Saul Bass drawing on Hadley's trust funds
adding.
We also rented a room on the
top floor or they shatty hotel.
Yeah.
He spent his mornings
perfecting the craft of writing.
He told himself that all he needed to
do was write one true sentence bars for
understanding way.
Being a writer meant seeing,
tasting,
and doing.
He spent hours observing people in Paris.
Cafes chatted freely with strangers
and spent long hours drinking with this
writing buddies in Paris.
Hemingway,
he was to come under the guidance of
celebrated author and playwright Gertrude
Stein.
She helped him to Paris words down to the
essence of the idea and to perfect the
style for which he would ultimately
become famous in 1923 they're having ways
that they took a trip to Spain that
sparking a lifelong love affair with the
Spanish culture.
Then people honest also fell in love with
the national obsession of bullfighting
in Pamplona.
The took his six month pregnant wife to
watch the running of the Bulls while she
hit her eyes from the spectacle
of a husband was spousal
bounds by the power and
the passion of the events.
I think we would return to the running
of the Bulls in Pamplona in the coming
years,
bringing a succession of
literary friends with him.
Okay.
These excursions.
They forms the backdrop
to his first novel.
The Sun also rises through his association
with F Scott Fitzgerald having boys
work came to the notice of Charles
Scribner publishers who published the Sun
also rises in 1926 this was
Hemingway's real breakthrough.
You're proving to be
both a commercial bands.
The critical success.
It's actually a day in a new minimalistic
writing style for which the world was
more than ready.
However,
not everyone was so
impressed by this book.
His mother sent him this scathing notes.
Surely you have other words in your
vocabulary besides dam and bitch as having
ways to start elevators.
His private life began to disintegrate.
He had frequent fallings out with his
or pals as he assumed the role of master
to their apprenticeships.
His temper,
it was volcanic,
sometimes lead to fist fights and things.
Unfortunately,
they are no better at home and threw
himself into a passionate affair with a
friend of his wife by the
name of Pauline Pfeiffer.
Hadley feeling deeply
betrayed by both sides.
Gave her first 100 days to
decide who you wanted to be with.
He chose the more cosmopolitan
Pfeiffer walked out.
I mean,
it's wifey son.
Okay.
Hemingway the also walked
out on Paris in Pauline,
who had made a second wife,
moved to the island of
Key West Florida here,
honest,
reinvented himself as
a deep sea fishermen,
integrating himself with a group of hard
working and hard drinking seafarers who
were a world away from the
gentle intellectuals that
had left behind in Paris.
Okay.
Fishermen Hemingway reveled in
the machismo of his new lifestyle.
During the day he fished along the Cuban
coast and at night he smuggled rum for
his local hangout with the
proceeds rolling in from
the sun also rises and does
next novel,
a farewell to arms.
He built his own boat,
calls the pillar and set about to
becoming the world's greatest deep sea
fishermen.
He proceeded to win every
fishing contest on the Atlantic.
When the locals became upset,
he told them that they
could win their trophy back,
but first they have to last three
rounds in a boxing ring with m and s.
Well,
nobody could,
but still during all of this time,
Hemingway's love it was writing.
He rose at 5:00 AM each day and it's
worked at his typewriter until midday.
During this time,
he would give his total
focus to the rest and worse.
Then after lunch,
he would throw himself into his
other life that have the hard living,
heavy drinking man of action.
Okay.
During the key west is instant.
Pauline has two children of their own.
Both of them putting Pauline through
marathon myriads of labor tabs.
Then well,
she proved to be a pretty terrible mother,
a woman who clearly did not like the
inconvenience of having children.
Hemingway himself.
Well,
he was also a lousy father.
He would have periods of intense interest
in his boys and then completely ignore
them for months at a time.
In 1933 having weight discovered a whole
new world of adventure when he set out
on a hunting safari in Africa,
he was mesmerized by the natural
beauty of the Serengeti plain justice.
He was getting into the hunt.
He was struck with a
terrible bout of dysentery.
He was flown to a hospital then Nairobi
to recover the plane that flew over the
majestic mountains.
Kilimanjaro providing the inspiration for
his most celebrated short story of the
it snows of Kilimanjaro after his recovery
having returned to the hunts where he
managed to bag buffalo out to low
pans and lions during all this time,
he was soaking up the atmosphere for
inclusion in the later works of fiction
back in key west.
Hemingway continued his
heart living lifestyle.
During the early thirties he began an
affair with an American woman who lived in
Havana honest,
would spend increasing amounts
of time with her in Cuba.
While this frustrated why I've
struggled to cope with the children.
Then in 1936 he began an affair with
Martha Gellhorn need journalist and writer
Gellhorn that had the same sense of
journalistic adventurous Hemingway.
And in 1937 they made the decision that
to cover the Spanish civil war together,
I think we arrived in Spain as a reporter
for the American newspaper Alliance.
However,
he seemed became involved in
a Dutch film production goals,
at least Spanish earth
when the screenwriter quit
need took on the duties for
himself.
After a few months,
seat returned to America,
showing the film in Hollywood and to
raising at $20,000 for the Spanish
Republicans.
His month in Spain provided the basis
for Hemingway's best selling novel about
the civil war for whom the bell tolls
those months while they also fueled the
flames of passion with Martha Gellhorn.
A short time after returning to key west,
he divorced.
Pauline said that tea.
Good Mary Martha.
In 1939 the newlyweds Steve moved to Cuba.
They settle into a beautiful villa on
the outskirts of Havana and he has a
couple of what to write to during the day
and to then explore the nice life that
Havana had to offer.
Cuba was also a sportsman's paradise,
allowing Hemingway,
do you indulge his great
passion for deep sea fishing,
having weight when he soon Matt and
aging Cuban fisherman by the name of
Gregorio Fuentes,
they became fishing buddies with Hemingway
basing the character of Santiago in
his Pulitzer Prize winning novel,
the old man and the sea,
a prominent Gregorio during the hurricane
season to Cuba that you Hemingway's,
they decided to live in Sun Valley,
Idaho.
Here.
Honesty was able to partake in the
hunting and fresh water fishing that he'd
done with his father as a boy.
During this time he became
close friends with stars.
Gary Cooper runs Marlene Dietrich.
He took on the life of something
of a celebrity himself.
Errol Flynn,
Jane Russell,
and Ingrid Bergman,
regular visitors to Sun
Valley back in Cuba.
He would in stain the likes of Spencer
Tracy and the Duchess of Windsor at the
Floridita bar in Havana.
It was Hemingway himself,
who was the acknowledged star of Havana.
The locals think we're always
delighted to have it in their midst.
They were just as impressed with his
ability to drink anyone under the table
Bosley where with this literary fame.
Yes.
Even as his wild nights on the town in
Nevada became more decadent and then
weight.
It never strayed from his
disciplined writing regimen.
He continued to produce quality
work with religious zeal.
One true sentence at a time,
and it was during this time that
international accolades began at showering
Hemingway in response to for whom the
bells toll this was widely regarded as a
literary masterpiece.
Ernest Hemingway,
the writer was transforming
himself into Papa Hemingway,
the white whisker literary genius,
who was also the big,
loud and burly Alpha male.
When World War Two they organize it has
also created tensions in far off Havana.
Martha Gellhorn Hemingway protect career
ahead of her family and set off to
Europe.
There's a war correspondent
novel Hemingway.
It was furious telling everyone within
earshot or that he had a good mind to
follow after her and kick her ass.
Good.
Tell her she should either come
home or go to military school.
Meanwhile,
Martha was becoming politically
active in support of the allies.
She encouraged Hemingway to use
his influence to rally support.
He ignored her pleas,
but finally I left for London as a
correspondence for Colliers magazine.
He joins the ref on
bombing missions and Holly,
the fourth infantry across
Normandy in the week of the d day.
Invasion on returning from the water
to form that having where greatly
exaggerated the party played in defeating
the Germans just as he had done at the
end of World War One.
The military got word
of his claims and again,
looking further into them,
they discovered that Hemingway had
violated his status as a noncombatant
reporter bond many occasions,
and he was charged with numerous rule
violations when it came to his defense of
number of high ranking officer's testified
with one stating that Hemingway was
without question.
One of the most courageous
men I've ever known.
Fear is a stranger to him having weight.
He was cleared of all charges and later
awarded a Bronze Star for bravery as a
war correspondent.
Okay.
Oh,
was ends.
Martha left the marriage,
fed up with our husbands
shamanistic tendencies,
but Hemingway,
well,
he already had a replacement in the wings.
It was a fellow walker respondents
by the name of the Mary Welsch.
Mary would be by his side,
right until the end.
In the late 1940s Hemingway's excessive
drinking began taking a toll on his
physical and mental health for the time
the quality of his writing began to
suffer,
which was hugely frustrating for him.
Finally after a trip to where to lead
during which he engaged in a passionate
affair with a gal in our twenties they
published across the river and into the
trees.
The critics,
they absolutely slammed it
and for the first time having,
we felt the sting of literary rejection,
the consensus as well as that the old man,
he no longer had the gift for having well.
This was like a red flag to a bull.
He completed his next
novel in just eight weeks.
That novel was the older man of the sea
and to became the defining work of his
career,
the aging champ,
he had regained his title
and with a vengeance,
silencing the critics and claiming Veem
1953 Pulitzer Prize for literature.
Then in 1954 Hemingway,
he was on safari in Africa.
When his light plane
went down in the jungle,
smashing his head against
the door to a furnace.
He saved the life of all onboard but
suffered permanent head injuries in the
wake of the Cuban revolution.
Hemingway's left Avanir in July
of 1960 and to move to Idaho here,
his health,
both mental and physical,
rapidly deteriorated.
He was admitted to the Mayo Clinic and
it's given electroshock therapy to treat
his depression.
This rob,
to the master wordsmith off his
greatest rating tool is memory.
And without that you have
nothing understanding why
he committed suicide with
his favorite hunting rifle on July 2nd,
1961 so I really hope
you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
And don't forget,
subscribe for brand new
videos just like this.
Twice a week we cover a
whole range of people,
some of which you can find
link to on the screen now.
Say,
be sure to check those out and as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.